you're still here it's over go home oh  you're expecting it's a little tease for  Deadpool - well we don't have that kind  of money spend it all on the suit oh oh  oh  but I can tell you one thing okay cable  is gonna be in the sequel yeah cable  he's like one of my favorite characters  in the whole wide yeah I'd love the guy  just need a big guy with a flat top I'm  thinking Dolph Lundgren  Newt Gingrich Grace Jones Keira  Knightley could be anybody but I'll go  go go go  600 pounds  Jimmy chunga four pairs of assless chaps  12 humiliating minutes on a gas tank  after 117 script pages 456 ad libs two  nerds seven magical unicorn three good  walls and a fourth that's broken did I  leave the stove on 42 rejection letters  from Fox in one leaked video and 783  million fans for your consideration fake  laugh hiding real pain Deadpool  you